now tonight we do send our all our love
all our prayers to everyone in uvalde
texas there
can you think of anything worse than
losing a child just for a second you
think about that aspect of it as
captured very well by sarah carter who's
been there with the families all day
yesterday we lost 19 innocent children
two brave teachers because of the evil
actions of a despicable soulless monster
uh you can't have a conscience or a soul
and and do something this evil right
but let me be clear though there is a
solution we've got to talk about
solutions most people don't want to get
to the root cause of anything but if we
want to protect our kids which we must
do and prevent this thing from happening
again we need an honest discussion
we protect our politicians they are
secured with police with secret service
with armed gunmen around them we pay for
that and rightfully so we should protect
our elected officials celebrities
athletes they all have bodyguards they
can afford it they deserve the
protection as well we just spent what 40
billion dollars uh that we sent
to ukraine to protect democracy
i think it's well past time that we as a
country maybe we should save a few of
those billions of dollars and send them
to every school in the country so they
can hire well-trained well-qualified
armed guards particularly retired police
officers retired military we can do that
if we choose to if we make it a priority
to protect every stadium every consular
venue every airplane in this country
that we all get on and use we can do the
same for our schools and for our
children without a doubt finding real
actionable solutions to protect our kids
is critically important and we don't
have to infringe on people's rights to
do so unfortunately sarah is right sadly
many on the left they're not interested
in a real solution in fact they don't
even really seem to care about gun
violence at all
unless and until it fits a preferred
political narrative now take a look at
your screen since 2019 5 4
598 children have been shot and killed
in the united states of those of that
number 43 of those deaths were school
shootings and of course we on this
program have stated over and over again
you know that this this literally is our
national treasure these lives these
precious kids all lives definitely
matter one death is a tragedy so why on
the left why do they seemingly always
ignore the young kids routinely being
gunned down in cities like baltimore and
washington d.c and new york los angeles
chicago every single week we had 28
people shot in chicago last week by the
way that's on the low side for a typical
weekend there no one on the left ever
talks about it they don't seem to care
on this program we have been scrolling
the names of murder victims people that
have been involved and have been shot in
the windy city we have done this since
2009
since that time
1381 children under the age of 19 have
been shot and killed in chicago that
includes eight years of the obama
biden uh presidency and vice presidency
but they could they couldn't be bothered
at the time they never addressed they
barely mentioned the epidemic of
violence in obama's home city of chicago
they didn't lift a finger they didn't
even try they didn't do next to nothing
they barely spoke about the carnage in
one of america's major cities so you got
to ask yourself a question why is that
well in short if democrats the media mob
and if they can't use a shooting to try
and vilify republicans or conservatives
what they just ignore it
how how is that possible
and then you listen to joe biden before
we even knew the the actual number of
people shot yesterday rushes to
politicize this so now sadly like always
they use the horror in uvalde texas to
score what cheap political points uh
because if they really cared about all
those kids why didn't they lift a finger
for joe eight years you were vice
president why didn't you do anything
last night before we even knew the
actual real death toll president biden
raced rushed in front of a camera
politicized the shooting lashing out at
the so-called gun lobby and meanwhile
them one democratic congressman takes to
twitter and calls ted cruz a bleeping
baby killer and then there's this
lunatic beto bozo o'rourke and he's
running again for statewide office it's
not going well for him so today he
interrupted an official press conference
in uvalde uh with his very own political
stunt take a look at this this circus
sir you are out of line
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
[ __ ] would come to a deal like this to
make a political issue
[Music]
this was supposed to be an informative
briefing for parents the community the
general public there were family members
of victims in that room there were
parents there in the room crying but
there's bozo didn't seem to care he
wanted to see his name in the headlines
he wanted to raise money for a
struggling campaign he wanted the focus
to be on him so as cbs news even
reported he orchestrated this disgusting
stunt from beginning to end take a look
could you make out what was being said
by better o'rourke
well i did see what happened just before
the press conference started i was in
the third uh third
aisle um
third row on the aisle rather and there
were two people across the aisle from me
and a moment before the press conference
started they got up from their seats
when bechto walked in so they were
seat holders for him and then he sat
down so his presence wasn't really
noticed in the 15 or 20 minutes that
people were gathering inside because he
was not in the room so this seems
something very clearly staged by beta or
work and his campaign
it was staged and beto bozo will lose
this election badly and by the way he's
all over the map now when it comes to
guns the second amendment let's go back
in time remember during his presidential
campaign that run remember he bragged
often about wanting to confiscate your
guns and hell yeah he's coming for your
ars and your
ak-47s uh well now as a gubernatorial
candidate in an election year conversion
he's trying to defend the second
amendment not what he did before
americans will who own ar-15s ak-47s
will have to sell them to the government
i fully expect our fellow americans to
turn in their ar-15s and their ak-47s
are you in fact in favor of gun
confiscation
yes hell yes we're going to take your
ar15 your ak-47 i'm not interested in
taking anything from anyone what i want
to make sure that we do is defend the
second amendment
oh now that he's running for governor he
wants to defend the second amendment no
we're not going to confiscate guns uh
just a tip
isn't this what we find so repulsive
about politicians they have no real
convictions and he'll say and do
anything to get elected
beto bozo is no hero here he's spineless
he's an out-of-work politician he wants
to feel important and he's politicizing
a tragedy the real
heroes if you will in uvalde were those
that risked their life and limb to save
as many kids as they could and they did
including the elite border patrol
official the one that rushed into robb
elementary school the one that returned
fire and ultimately killed this murderer
and by the way just take a look at this
this is his hat take a good look at that
as you can see came within millimeters
of losing his own life hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else